To my sisters, to spirit kin and gender diverse relatives,
hear me when I say this.
We are our own liberators.
For far too long, our realities have been silenced,
our voices absent, our bodies subjugated to the violence of colonialism
and our spaces made to shrink.
Those days are over.
This is the era of matriarchy
where we heal and where we thrive,
where we take up space, where we take up all of the space.
We are strong, resilient,
generous, fears,
compassionate and we are deeply loving.
We are the descendants of warriors,
matriarchs, storytellers and teachers.
We are our ancestors greatest legacy.
We are the next generation of ancestors.
So live in that sacredness.
Step into your power. Live your fullest,
most joyful, vibrant life. We deserve nothing less.